isn't a term based such a great word as
in this is based on a true story Cool
Runnings definitely exploited that word
when it was telling the story of Olympic
Jamaicans who actually made it into a
bobsled competition I get the feeling
this film could have been a really
dramatic really fascinating story of
Hills done by like touchstone or
paramount or something but because it's
Disney we got a play of the goofy and
funny Ness of these guys trying to make
it in the Winter Olympics and with the
film of them better if it didn't deal
with that corny point of view probably
but at the same time I kind of like the
corny point of view in this yea I'm
really torn about this because on the
one hand it is silly and the Jamaicans
are more like the Ninja Turtles and
their personalities and how colorful and
goofy they are but at the same time I
kind of like the Ninja Turtles then
let's look at the story a Jamaican wants
to run in the Olympics but when an
accident happens literally tripping him
up it looks like his chances are gone
forever until he finds out there's
another way to get in through
bobsledding there's only two problems
one there in Jamaica and nobody can do
bobsledding and two he doesn't even know
what a bobsled is but as luck would have
it an old drunken bobsledder played by
John Candy happens to be in the
neighborhood and they keep pestering him
and pestering him until he finally
agrees that he'll try to train them they
get a team together do their best to try
and learn how to do it on hills without
ice and sure enough John Candy says
they're ready to go when they get to the
Olympics of course everybody laughs and
mocks them and thinks they can't go
anywhere and at first they don't they
start to choke but then on the second go
they start to actually do a really good
job and everybody is suddenly on their
side all building up to the final
competition as a kid I love this movie I
love how goofy everybody does I love how
colourful they were I love how they all
had distinct personalities I love how
they
have their own little back stories like
one one to live in Buckingham Palace
even though he wasn't aware it was
Buckingham Palace but as an adult wait
one one to live in Buckingham Palace
even though he didn't know as Buckingham
pet what you got bullies in this movie
that are played by the Germans which
yeah on the one hand is kind of funny
and how silly it is on the other hand
really the ending which I won't give
away is actually a very heartfelt and
inspiring ending but yeah even that goes
a little too corny it's just I don't
know there's a very fine line of an
audience that will like this movie you
have to be ready for that corniness you
have to be ready for the slow clap and
the dramatic turn and the really corny
goofy moments with the really corny
goofy music playing and okay let's say
you're not a fan of that is there
anything in this film that's redeemable
well once again as with practically any
role that he's in John Candy is
fantastic every time you see this guy on
screen you always shout man did he leave
too soon
why didn't we appreciate him more when
he was around he just took every role
that he did so seriously whether it was
a comedy or a drama or something in
between like this
he captures the pain and weight of a guy
who cheated in the Olympics originally
but then wanted to come back you want to
do it because he felt it was right and
he wanted to give other people a chance
he wanted to do it because that's what
the Olympics are and you hear that in
every breath that he takes but aside
from that is the film worth checking out
I guess it's sort of like Disney's The
Hunchback of Notre Dom if you can accept
that Disney is above-the-title and that
the actual story it's based on is not
gonna be represented that well you can
still find a relatively entertaining
movie even if there are a lot and I mean
a lot of corny Disney isms but to all
the actors credit they do what they need
to do pretty well when they need to have
the funny moments they're pretty funny
and over-the-top and when they need to
have the dramatic moments they do that
fine to are the side stories really
forced and contrived yes did they
probably not
happen most likely but you do get a lot
of heart from these guys and you can
definitely feel it on screen so it's
definitely a mixed bag for me the film
is harmless and allowed for some fun
humor and even a few inspiring moments
even if they are really corny it's kind
of like those old 80's movies that you
watch that you know are really hokey but
you can't help but enjoy because there's
just so much passion behind it I think
it's sort of the same case here I think
that should give you a general idea if
this is a film you're going to enjoy or
not and even though the silliness of
again via little teeth grinding at times
I can't find myself saying I didn't
actually enjoy it I did I enjoy the
cheesy lines I enjoy the annoying
one-liners and I enjoy it because
there's still a lot of heart behind it
yeah there's a lot of fault but in my
heart felt nostalgic mind there's no
problem see it's so corny it's even
having me say lines like that
you